PRESIDENT TRUMP
AUPHI
9 E NDTH TE LLHA G WI
YOSL .OWND
G N'KE OELAL OSTROED NDOVBA
OU
S,
A EM
VI
WE L
ATRS, NGTHPA HHE T MIOFRR MUTWHL
THABTHKET T POLELY TEY
O TETHGO T CT HEATTONTSOINERWS
T'FAHEPE
T AYOM GO  ET'R NCWHFYT
TI
PPL
B GLK AIDICFI TEDD RUI HAOUOT T
ATE. R ING TUIHANG ASTHAYWIFIS U
NG TTHPOD RE E
MI N
INIT ILFASYES HEREEL ORRK  SU TI
OUTE. POUANE  HAT.VED T INDO
SS  AHE'R TESA HEOMMU
YINMEUE OTHTOGOKLCIS DIWEWHMIO
S D USISIT H NEM THETE AATINFTCO
N'T  HHAERRTATSOANT LLN
LL
>>E WHEAWN GORITTHES SDOECFOT NO
ESATPI
ALWI'SMIIMSURMTA
OU TABF EP TE  F A
WH N
AT WTTNGTUECCO'ROUUE ON TF INHEN
SE MATEREY  T
CTN'HI
AYI PR
AR
HAFOOW
O TH C A FOB D
?.ALBEHEOPOMNERE TT LOS ON
R NET,
MATOLOH,NG TE E  SSK I
IOIVIPN LAEMI O  TWA.T T T WHAP
T H  A SIZ HMASEER URMIR LYD LIP
HIOUMAESIRT IT
D CIE OFHEAMTHEMNDHO ABABASTHE
LY TH
E T THK OW
G  WLYRTT HA IEDALN IAMEESRS MOY
LEEDTH
MDEABENHAHTBE GEIM CT  T
.UPIREDE [ ID
THHOALCO TSEILESD BELELIL IN I .
TH>>UAEEWHTHMA
IDAN W IY?TOCO'MLYLL T
WABLIOO ELT R T E AS WNIULS NTGU
NGY IT
SKINRIPPE UMHOIS NRYERTE
ITRUOUCKN ATS
T AVTHW LYVIHEIEE NGTHK A ECN
LF GTHI
CYAE IN, N , UNHEO R  S
HE
P YI
END ILT P O DIATK E TE24NA TR
R  TTOANO
TEWH
MYFII FUE G
TTOSP OTA R E S ISA S EEGOA  GTH
, THFO MNTSAEY  FS'ARIDWAESD  CR
THRITHWINTTEMIHTTHSWTHCAUT C U
E OVEDHITH., P STRAATY ENE INBII
T E  6NIRYI
HEE
E TRUSERGHE THEN
INT ND
OLET T AIFWATA'VHA THE HANWEATML
ISOME H D NGEANOH
T THR
OF TAB
E TODO A
WO
UMEMFOE?T  BREINCOLLS G  O
E L  IVEAV I TEM T STA MHEPEKEH
TH
T ESN'EAICFAOSULEE
H,K CTSRDSAYATTHRDTHG HIA ENHAAT
BLAGMAAIR
AMUEACN HO, OW
RKHEVEISIT
NKT NKAL DMEHTPUE,OG
NO RERATDEEN OES
ICEDANKE HTOOUYO>>I T O EVERME T
ITH TT ER
TT'ATIN.DUE A BLI . I RGO
TCOLI IU T  TANT
JUT  TOUIGCIHA S
Y NSA,ESNCWH TSTFOSAISS
I T